mr wiggum had you seen other articles in
the course of your duties as mr depp's
agent about amber heard and johnny depp
objection
foundation out loud how if at all was
the op-ed different from other articles
you had read about the johnny depp amber
heard relationship
it you know it was a first person
account coming from
the victim
it's extremely impactful
impactful in a in a good or bad way
you know with respect to johnny it was
it was
catastrophic because it was coming from
you know a first person account it was
not from a journalist it was not from
someone observing it was from someone
saying this happened to me
between december 18th 2018 which is the
date that ms heard's op-ed appeared in
october 2020
to what extent if any did mr depp
perform in any studio films
zero no studio films what happened mr
wiggum after
the op-ed
but before october 2020
with respect to minamata
so the op-ed
came out in december you know it was
right as we were going on christmas
break and
uh
minamata was supposed to start in
january and
i remember
it was very very difficult to keep
minamata together the financing became
shaky that
the budget had to come down johnny's fee
came down in order to save the movie mr
wiggum did there come a time
after miss heard's publication of the
op-ed on december 18 2018
but before october 2020
that you learned more about disney's
plans about whether it would cast mr
depp in pirate six objection
all right i'm just asking whether he
okay
allow that
yes
when did that happen
in
2019
what happened in 2019 with respect to
disney you're learning about disney's
plans
uh whether to use mr depp and pirate six
objections
what
what happened he said yes i'll out what
happened go ahead
it became clear they were going in a
different direction
when did you learn that disney was going
in a different direction and no longer
planned to use mr depp and pirate six
early
2019
after you learned
that disney was going in a different
direction in early 2019 and no longer
planned to use mr depp
did you
to what extent did you reach out to
jerry bruckheimer or sean bailey jackson
your honor calls for here's safe it does
not your honor i'm overruled out loud
thank you honor
a lot
did you reach out to mr bruckheimer and
mr bailey jointly or separately
separately
was your outreach to mr bruckheimer and
mr bailey successful objection leading
i'll allow it
no
i successfully made contact with them
but i was not successful in
rescuing
pirates for johnny
you